carolina probó una hipótesis nula la
cual dice que la media real de la
población de cierto conjunto de datos es
igual a 0 contra la hipótesis
alternativa la cual dice que la media
real de la población no es igual a 0 con
una muestra de 6 observaciones y el
estadístico t desmuestra fue t igual a
2.75 supón que se cumplen las
condiciones de inferencia cuál es el
valor p aproximado para la prueba de
carolina como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta siempre es bueno comenzar
tratando de comprender lo que nos están
diciendo aquí tenemos una población y la
hipótesis nula dice que la media de la
población es igual a cero
la hipótesis alternativa dice que la
media de la población no es igual a cero
ella quiere probar la hipótesis nula por
lo que toma una muestra de tamaño 6 como
el estadístico de interés es la media de
la población ella calcula la media
muestral y la desviación estándar
muestral para poder estimar este valor
después usa esto para calcular el valor
de este valor es igual a la media
muestral menos la media supuesta de la
población indicada en la hipótesis nula
esto es
qué significa este sub zero de acá esta
media estará dividida entre el estimado
de la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral y decimos que es
el estimado porque a diferencia de
cuando tratamos con proporciones donde
podemos calcular la desviación estándar
supuesta de la distribución muestral con
base en la hipótesis nula aquí tenemos
que estimar la esto va a ser la
desviación estándar muestral entre la
raíz cuadrada de n en este ejemplo ya
han calculado este valor nos dicen que
es igual a 2.75 así que podemos usarlo
para encontrar el valor p pensemos en
que es lo que nos piden hacer la
hipótesis nula dice que la media es
igual a cero la alternativa dice que la
media no es igual a cero si imaginamos
la distribución t y ésta es la media de
la distribución t nos interesa lo que
está al menos dos puntos 75 desviaciones
estándar por arriba de la media y 2.75
desviaciones estándar por debajo de la
media pues nos interesan las cosas que
están alejadas de la media y no las
cosas que son mayores o menores que la
media nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de tener un valor t
al menos 2 puntos 75 veces arriba de la
media y cuál es la probabilidad de tener
un valor de que está al menos 2 puntos
75 veces por debajo de la media menos
2.75 aquí tenemos una tabla t y esta
tabla es algo diferente que la tabla
zeta primero tenemos los grados de
libertad gl que es el tamaño de la
muestra menos 1 en nuestro ejemplo el
tamaño de la muestra es 6 por lo que los
grados de libertad son 5 así que nos
ubicamos en este renglón
una vez que ubicamos el renglón vamos a
buscar el valor t así que en este
renglón
vamos a buscar 2.75 y encontramos que el
valor más cercano es 2.757 así que la
probabilidad de la cola y recuerden que
esta tabla nos da solamente esta
probabilidad de aquí así que la
probabilidad de la cola está entre 0.0
25 y 0.02 estamos más cerca de 0.02 de
hecho es un poquito más grande porque
nuestro valor es algo menor que 2.700 57
podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 0.02 y como la
probabilidad es simétrica en este otro
lado también tenemos que es
aproximadamente igual a 0.02 el valor p
que es la probabilidad de obtener el
valor t que está al menos 2 puntos 75
por arriba de la media y 2.75 por debajo
de la media así que el valor p es la
suma de estas áreas será aproximadamente
igual a 0.04 una vez encontrado el valor
p
carolina va a comparar este valor con el
nivel de significancia que haya
determinado previamente y si este valor
es menor que ese nivel entonces va a
rechazar la hipótesis nula y sospechar a
la validez de la alternativa si el valor
p es mayor que su nivel de significancia
entonces no rechazará la hipótesis nula
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo